well thank you very much
we had some good news the market hit a
all-time high today the SMP just broke
its record so what very happy about that
stock market continues to do well jobs
have been literally through the roof and
speaking of jobs we have the u.s. MCA
Canada Mexico and we've come a long way
with the great agreement is you know
Mexico yesterday approved it with a very
positive vote and you're doing very well
understand also we are but it's an honor
to have the Prime Minister of Canada
Justin Trudeau it's been a friend of
mine we've worked hard together we work
in particular on the u.s. MCA and we
hope to have bipartisan support I think
Justin you're going to be making the
rounds of Congress it's a terrific thing
but it's great to have you so what are
we talking about that and generally will
be talking trade and other things and
we're then going to have lunch and some
meetings and it's an interesting day but
it'll be like a positive day I think
like usual that's the way we want to
have it we want to have very positive
days we only have positive days so I
want to thank you very much thank you
Donald for for this meeting it's an
opportunity for us as you say to keep
talking about how we've worked hard to
great build a great trade deal that's
good for Canadian workers for American
workers good for Mexican workers as well
we're moving forward on the ratification
process aligned with you obviously today
as well on top of the great news in the
Canadian and American economies we're
continuing to work on rod range of
global issues this is just a really
great opportunity for us to continue to
work and to develop and to build on the
closest alliance in the world between
Canada and the United States well this
will be the largest trade deal ever made
and it won't even be close if you take a
look at the numbers second is so far
away you don't even call it second so
it's very exciting and very exciting
from Mexico very exciting for candidate
I have to also thank the President of
Mexico because he's really been doing a
job on the border and a job in Mexico a
lot of very positive things have
happened and the flow has very
substantially slowed down they have
6,000 Mexican troops on their southern
border and it's been it's really been a
tremendous difference I want to thank
Mexico are the people of Mexico now this
has only been for a short period of time
our country has been asking for this for
45 years approximately and they're doing
it now and we very much appreciate that
Mexico's doing that it's gonna have a
big impact it's already had a big impact
so with that I thank you very much and
we're gonna get on with our discussions
I was going to say this is the new West
listen that's which we ordered which
they've been trying to order for a lot
of years we were able to shave 1.5
billion dollars off the price when I got
here then we're going to spend a lot
more money than we spent and I would say
the plane basically is an upgrade over
that model we actually are getting
things that they didn't get we're saving
about 1.5 billion dollars so it's going
to be terrific it's under construction
right now by Boeing go ahead I made a
big mistake this drone was in
international waters clearly we have it
all documented it's documented
scientifically not just words and they
made a very bad mistake
talking too much about it you're gonna
find out they made a very big mistake no
concerns we'll be discussing that it'll
be one of the issues I think we'll be
discussing right now with Justin well I
guess they indicated they're gonna be
lower we should have done it sooner but
what are you gonna do can't win of all
he should have done it sooner but you
can't win it all and eventually he'll do
what's right perhaps let's see what he
does we're very concerned about the
escalation by around recently we have
significant presence in the area
the omission in in Baghdad in Iraq we
look forward to discussing with closest
ally effectives on this and well I don't
know that he's trying to move we've got
a lot of things to discuss well
otherwise I'll represent him well I will
tell you we have a meeting set up with
President Xi and it's obviously on the
big transaction that we're talking about
and negotiate and what people are
actually speaking now we'll see what
happens with that but anything I can do
to help Canada I will be doing I would
at Justin's request I will absolutely
bring because so far I have to get the
Democrats to approve it alright so I
like your positive thinking but if and
the if is really subject to the
Democrats let's see what happens but I
really believe that Nancy Pelosi and the
house will approve it I think the Senate
will approve it rapidly it's gonna be
very bipartisan it's great for the
farmers manufacturers it's really great
for everybody and unions it's great for
unions I mean I we have tremendous union
support too
it's a tremendous it really is it shows
a partnership between three countries
and sort of three countries in a trade
sense we're competing with the European
Union we're competing with China it
gives us a bigger dialogue because
that's a much bigger platform it's
really good for all three it's something
that's very popular
I hope politically they can do what they
have to do now a day after the election
it would win with a tremendous support
but we have an election coming up but I
think Nancy Pelosi is going to do the
right thing
well we'll see I mean you know they have
to do what they have to do we understand
that we can't have a tremendous
shipments of certain products so we
understand them very well we were very
pleased with the tariffs on steel there
won't be hopefully transshipping if
there's grand shipping alcohol justin
and imperial take care of it doesn't
probably call them a second time and if
he doesn't then we'll have to talk but I
think that I think that that situation
is very well taken care very important
for both countries and for all three
countries the farmers very very
important more so in that case from US
and Canada but the farmers are really
happy with it the manufacturers are very
happy
Mexico is thrilled you saw the vote was
a very lopsided in a positive way vote a
great vote and I think it's going to be
something very special again it's a
largest trade deal by far ever entered
into and we're very close to haven't
finalized it means a lot of jobs for our
country a lot of wealth for all three
countries and we're really competing
against the world you know we're not
competing with each other so much this
brings us into a position where we're
not competing with each other we're
competing against the world and that's
what we're doing we're competing against
big sections of the world including Asia
and including other areas and I think
it's going to be very special I think
it's going to end up being a very
important deal but the biggest ever made
well we thought about that that's an
interesting question
they played phenomenal basketball I
watched a little bit of it they were
really terrific congratulations by the
way that was a great job by a great team
so we'll think about that I'd like to do
it we'll think about that we have a lot
of other folks coming and the
presidential medal I just spoke to them
we're going to be presenting the
Presidential Medal of Freedom to Roger
Penske Roger Penske is a great gentleman
who has won 18 Indianapolis 500 s he's
won just one Daytona
we won Daytona he wanted
the Annapolis e1 probably more than
anybody in the history of racing I can't
imagine anybody even being close but
Roger Penske is going to be getting the
Medal of Freedom and he's very thrilled
to be getting it and that'll be
announced over the next little while but
I guess actually I'm announcing pretty
much putting something out they'll be
putting something out in a little while
he's very deserving he's a great
gentleman I've known him a long time and
a very brilliant guy when you think of
all the countries that want to win
Indianapolis and Daytona and they fight
and they spend even Canada they spend a
lot of money and they and you know when
a man wins Indianapolis when he wins at
18 times and he just won the Daytona and
he won many things over the course of
years and he's become a very successful
man we talked about electric cars today
I think nobody knows more about that
subject in terms of common sense than
Roger Penske so Roger Penske will be
getting and receiving the Presidential
Medal of Freedom
oh absolutely when I came here Iran was
in 14 to 18 different sites of
confliction they were extremely hostile
they were hostile when they signed the
deal they were screaming death to
America and I think probably Iran made a
mistake I would imagine it was a general
or somebody that made a mistake in
shooting that drone down and fortunately
that drone was unarmed it was not there
was no man in it and there was no it was
just it was over international what is
clearly over international waters but we
didn't have a man or woman in the drone
we had nobody in the drone would have
made a big difference let me tell you
would have made a big big difference but
I have a feeling I may be wrong and I
may be right but I'm right a lot I have
a feeling that it was a mistake made by
somebody that shouldn't have been doing
what they did I think they made a
mistake and I'm not just talking about
the country made a mistake I think that
somebody under the command of that
country made a big
your phone so let's just see what
happens you just let's see what happens
it's all gonna work out you don't I
don't know I find it hard to believe it
was intentional if you want to know the
truth I think that it could have been
somebody who was loose and stupid that
did it
we'll be able to report back and you'll
understand exactly what happened but it
was a very foolish move in fact in many
cases it's the opposite
but I will say look I said I want to get
out of these endless wars I campaigned
on that I want to get out we've been in
Afghanistan for 19 years as you know
we've reduced very substantially in
Afghanistan we beat the caliphate we
took back a hundred percent of the
Caliphate when it was 99 percent Justin
I said we're gonna get asked with him to
start peeling back and everybody went
crazy because it was 99 so I said all
right so we'll finish it up so we got a
hundred percent and we're pulling that
back out of Syria we're pulling a lot of
people back but this is something this
is a new wrinkle this is a new fly in
the ointment what happened shooting down
the drone and this country will not
stand for that I can tell you thank you
very much
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]